hey what's up guys my name is a Chennai
welcome to episode 77 of game
programming so when I continue to
particle class in this episode and
hopefully get some actual animation
going so what we've got right now is a
simple particle class here oh let me
mention straight away that I made an
error pretty big error in the last
episode not many of you pointed out I
think only one person did but it was a
pretty big error and I guess that's what
resolving me being tired so what I did
here is obviously this this particles
ArrayList was a bit flawed here and I'll
explain why in a minute
so basically the deal is that if you use
this constructor which is probably going
to be the most common constructor we use
because um usually you want more than
one particle right what happens is when
we use this constructor we actually you
know called this and that's all fine but
over here what we do is we add to the
particle array a new instance of this
constructor right and what this
constructor does is it adds itself into
the particle array so what we're doing
is we're actually adding the same
instance twice and what so basically
what we're doing is going to end up with
twice the particles that we want so what
we should really do is we could do this
multiple ways the easiest way is
probably just to remove these particles
to add thing but the thing is that's not
exactly going to work if we do it this
way and the reason that's not going to
work is because these guys are going to
create their own instances of this
particles ArrayList and that's not
really gonna work so the best way to do
it is not to do that is actually to get
rid of this particle so add this here
okay and just have it like that okay and
in that case we don't need this thing
here well we do kind of but what we need
to do is actually manually add it so
particles dot add this okay and what
that will do is that will instantiate
all of these values for us that we want
to instantiate here and then it will add
itself into the thing in fact we should
probably do this after just for good
practice as well as adding of course new
instances into it okay so that's a
that's a that's actually a thing
for a potential bug in the future not a
game breaking bugs but certainly just
not what we want to happen the game so
now that's out of the way let's continue
so the thing is what we want to do now
is animate these particles now to do
that as you know when we do any kind of
animation we have variables called X a
and y a okay and that's essentially just
the the X amount that we want to move by
and the Y amount that we want to move by
so let's go ahead and do that now we'll
make those two variables but because
particles and you know the whole um the
whole deal with um with having a
particle animation is that it's to do
with physics and so like that we want to
have doubles as the as the actual type
of variable here not integers so over
here on the life I'm just gonna make to
protect events if that life is probably
be protected and sorry not in doubles
called X a and y a okay and this is
going to be essentially the amount of
pixels it moves in the x axis and y a is
going to be the amount of pixels it
moved by on the y axis and someone was
calling me sorry
as if my friend was ringing okay so yeah
so this is gonna be the amount of pixels
that we move by on the y axis now these
are doubles because we're going to do
some pretty advanced maths on them so
what we want to do is obviously give
these guys a value now in entity we do
have this random thing here which is
good so we'll use that over here in
particles on the sprite I'm just gonna
make the Vista XA equal to random dot
next and Gaussian now you guys might be
like war on earth his next course in
Gaussian is essentially it's gonna give
you a random number between about -1 and
1 so between negative 1 and 1 except
it's gonna give you a normal
distribution of it so in other words
gonna give you like a bell curve
distribution so it'll be more likely for
the numbers to be around 0 than around 1
or negative 1 okay so you guys can
search out a bit more about that in in
the if you want on on the internet it's
a it's a Gaussian or no
distributer I'm not sure I've never
heard of being called ghosting before
that's just don't know what they called
that but it is a normally distributed
distributed value so if you've done on
statistics or someone that you probably
know what that is
am I covered in in more than the
in-depth series if I ever end up doing
that but um live like that for now and
we'll do the same for ye and obviously
this is gonna give them different value
since we're calling this next Gaussian
method again and that's pretty good okay
that's um that's looking pretty good so
once we've done this all we want to do
is kind of animate it and we can see
what that looks like okay this this will
be interesting if we just go ahead and
because I really want to like to break
this down for you guys to make it um you
know just a bit more legible on so you
guys can really understand what's going
on here so we're gonna hit up this dot y
equal to x + y now clearly these guys
are not not integers right so we can't
do that now we could do this right we
could do we put of course just cast it
to an integer but the thing is we're
gonna lose a lot of precision and a lot
of data by doing this because it's going
to actually and she bet basically make
it make this only move by 1 or negative
1 and that's going to be a bit of a
problem so we can't really do it that
way instead what we need to do is make 2
more doubles called xx and YY I'm just
going this like just for I don't know
because it makes sense but you guys can
call this whatever you want is basically
our actual X variable so we'll set this
dot X X equal to X and this dou y equal
to Y okay now the difference of course
between X X and X is that f is an
integer and xx is a double that's a big
difference
because now what we can do is actually
do this operation and only cost it to an
integer when we render it so let's take
a look at rendering this rendering this
is gonna be pretty simple
all right screen dot render sprite okay
and we'll render it at xx YY with the
sprite and think what on earth fixed oh
yes of course yeah true
fixed means that it it's like much
interact well thanks so in other words
it moves with the map it's stuck to the
level now of course that gives us an
error because
providing two doubles here so all we
need to do here is cause it to an
integer
all right and this will give us
precision right because this is where
we're rendering in here so it's cool to
do this this is gonna give us maximum
there's gonna still room it so this
guy's still give us maximum precision
here okay cool
right so that's um oh did I really do
this I meant plus equals whoops um so
that's going to essentially give us some
basic particle animation what we're
gonna do probably in the next step so
I'll demonstrate this in a minute and
probably play around with it but in the
next episode we'll cover a more advanced
Z variable so in other words we'll
simulate more or less depth but but more
of um it's not really depth it's more of
um like the floor will kind of simulate
a floor so that particles can bounce off
of the floor and kind of you know maybe
stop and not just go down forever
because that's obviously not realistic
in this kind of environment but let's
take a little what we've got here so
what would you do now is actually create
a bunch of particles now for me the best
way to test this obviously because we
could just spawn a bunch here but the
best way to test this is probably going
to be on collision that's just how I
like to do it so let's open up the mob
class and over here basically let's just
say that if there is a collision so in
other words if there's no collision
we'll move to player if there is a
collision though let's actually add a
bunch of particles to the map at the
players location so we can do that
really simply we'll make a new particle
here called particle P for example equal
new equals new particle and X will will
hit 2x + y it will set to Y so the
players x and y life we haven't
implemented that yet so it really
doesn't matter what it is and amount
will set to 50 okay and once we've done
that let's go ahead and add this to the
level remember you have to do that so
there are updates and renders so level
don't add pay okay so now we've added
this part of this base particles to
level Plus hit the debug button or the
Run button whatever and see if this
works
okay so you can see we get a bunch of
particles when we crash into the the
wall okay so every time we crash the
world we get a bunch of particles now
that's cool but the issue with that is
that um well first of all we haven't
inflated life yet so this guy's actually
stay here forever as you can see but
also the problem is that you can kind of
see there's no gravity right let's
increase this a bit make sure don't put
this up too high because obviously we
haven't actually implemented the removal
of them so that's the problem let's set
this maybe to 500 in performances
performance should be very good with us
especially when we when we implement the
removal let's go up here okay
so what we're getting here is more or
less no gravity right this is kind of
happening we're kind of you know they're
kind of going everywhere because of
course this is a Gaussian distribution
but the the issue that we have here and
you can see that the cool thing about
this is there at random spades as well
the issue with this is that they don't
really have any gravity they kind of
keep going forever and they don't you
know they're feel like they actually hit
the floor or anything so that's what we
want to talk about next episode because
it's a bit more complex but essentially
that's that's how that works okay so I
hope you enjoyed this episode of game
programming one thing that we could do
probably just to probably seem like this
a bit better is instead of having this
happening when we hit the wall let's
actually set it off at a projectile
collision so in in our projectile class
specifically in our wizard projectile
we've got the in update if there's a
tile collision removed let's actually to
that let's actually just add this code
into that okay now what's the deal here
okay so we need to cast this into an
integer
okay let's take a look at that so now if
we shoot we should get a bunch of
particles here yeah so you can see how
that's kind of working we're only
getting a few for some reason but we'll
talk about that more next episode as we
implement the other stuff but um
essentially what's happening here is
we're getting particles as we crash into
as we as our projectile shoots in the
wall so yeah anyway guys I hope you
enjoyed this episode again programming
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye
you